tanzania's president john magafuli has
died of heart failure at age 61. he had
not appeared in public for several weeks
leading to speculation that he
may have contracted covet 19 and been
flown abroad for treatment
michael fully had repeatedly played down
the risk of the coronavirus and warned
against
taking vaccines
he hadn't been seen in public for nearly
three weeks
many began speculating that tanzania's
president john magufuli
was in bad health now vice president
sameel asuhu
addressed the nation to say the
president had died of heart failure
feudal arrangements are being made
and you will be notified
our country shall be in a morning period
of 14 days
and the flags shall fly at half
heart complications for over 10 years
the popular leader was elected in 2015
and made a name for himself as a
corruption-busting man of the people
his supporters expressed dismay at his
death
[Music]
i feel very sad and i am suffering
because
we had our leader our president we loved
him
and he loved us the poor we were really
shocked by the news
the death of our beloved president
it hit us hard the whole of tanzania as
a nation has been hit hard
but for me personally i am deeply
affected
it was only last year that magafuli was
re-elected president
but despite that support opposition
figures accused him of cracking down on
descent
but recent criticism has focused on his
handling of the coronavirus pandemic
he drastically downplayed the effects of
the virus
calling on people to use prayer instead
of masks
in all this government no one wears a
mask
including me it proves there is no
coronavirus
and god loves this nation nothing is
impossible
for god
the government of tanzania stopped
publishing infection numbers
last year
death means his deputy will become the
nation's first
female president we're joined now by
journalist
isaac lucando in dar es salaam isaac
john magafuli reportedly died of a heart
condition but there had been a
lot of speculation that he had caught
covet 19. was that ever confirmed
uh thanks for having me those rumors
were
not confirmed and they remained thus as
rumors according to the government
because the government came out
yesterday on the 17th of march
giving the cause of death of president
john mcfully that it was related to
an a chronic actual fibrillation or
an irregular rhythm of the heart and the
government stated that this
condition he had been battling with
for over 10 years and it is no
secret that he had been battling
some form of a heart ailment so this was
this this information was public
knowledge
now margaret fully had been in charge
since 2015.
how will he be remembered in tanzania
um uh just judging by the the sheer
amount of texts going about on social
media particularly what's up here
in dar islam in in tanzania
tanzanians see him as a hero
most people uh i've seen on whatsapp
[Music]
emoji tier emojis uh people sharing
those
and expressing heartbreak some of the
people that i had met were in tears
and the fact that the the president had
uh had
passed on still a lot of people in shock
and disbelief
that the president had passed on
contrary to the image that he
had outside the country within the
country
he was and is hailed as a revolutionary
leader
as part of the report was saying that
he came in uh made sweeping changes
to how government run was very efficient
um
he was termed obviously as the bulldozer
for getting things done
and very action oriented and so to
this endeared him to a lot of tanzanians
who
now see him as a as a hero a fallen hero
now vice president samia hassan is due
to be sworn in as the country's first
female president what more can you tell
us about her
uh well samia sulu hassan was very close
to to the to the president at some point
uh president marco foley had
had elaborated not too long ago during
the
the elections last year that the reason
why he chose he had two picks the
president of zanzibar
and samir sulu hassan for vice president
to run as vice president
and he told the president the now
president of zanzibar
that the reason why he wasn't picked for
the position
was because samyasulu hassan was a woman
and he believed
in the abilities of women and wanted to
advance the
the cause of women obviously uh first in
tanzania in history to have a vice
president who was a female and now
um as acting president will now take on
the reigns as the president
of the united republic of tanzania also
a first
isaac thank you very much that was
journalist isaac lucando in
dar es salaam
you